now we all know you gotta fight for your
right to party but there's no fighting
when it comes to our right to Sparty and
joining us to tell us what asparty is is
our group sales manager from Red Rock
Spa and Salon Isabella Casanova welcome
thank you thank you so much what is a
Sparty absolutely so asparty is exactly
what it sounds like a spa party so it's
a celebration
um as long as you have five or more spa
services booked with us so facials or
massages you qualify to help us party
that sounds like the perfect opportunity
to grab a bunch of your girlfriends go
there get some relaxation but you can
also enhance it and make it more about
Wellness tell us how we can enhance it
with maybe a fitness class yeah
absolutely so like I mentioned as long
as five or more spa services are booked
you qualify for this party and then to
enhance it a great way now is to maybe
start with a group yoga session or maybe
a group boot camp class to start the day
that sounds so great and and not only
that but you say you know facials you
have
um group fitness and you also have food
and drinks that can enhance that tell us
a little bit about that yeah so um with
every Sparty we do include a
complimentary Spa Cabana at our spa but
we also have an amazing private room
that can be booked and we can totally
enhance that with a beautiful picnic
setup elaborate food and beverage so
whatever the group is looking to have
done the spa salon at Red Rock Hotel and
Casino is absolutely incredible and you
don't walk away empty-handed either tell
us about this bag of goodies that you
might get yeah absolutely so for our
groups that have nine or more spa
services we do include a little Sparty
gift bag we have some fun samples inside
like our Babor products so each person
will leave with one of these goodies
it's first class all the way now if
people are interested in doing this
setting it up can they do it for any
occasion does it have to be specifically
just for your gal Pals or what can you
do it for yeah absolutely so with
February right around the corner
gallentines is the perfect way to
celebrate we do a lot of bachelorettes
Bachelor parties birthdays team
appreciation so however you want to
celebrate how did we do this who do we
call how do we get in touch with you to
do this absolutely so you'll just want
to give our spa a call and then they
will actually go ahead and connect you
over to me that sounds like so much fun
a great way to celebrate a birthday an
anniversary like you said galentine's
Day is coming up that is the way to do
it thank you so much for joining us
today Isabella and make sure you reach
out to Red Rock Hotel Casino and